I'll thank everyone at the beginning
then the thanks are done and I would
like to talk to you about money and life
and I think that this follows
beautifully oops
well except that's fine beautifully from
the last presentation by Claire
in thinking about the relationship
between money and life first I'd like to
remind you of something that Claire just
said which is that an economy is social
relations well for me as an
anthropologist money is also social
relations all that money is is a record
of our credit and debts with one another
as anthropologists as diverse as most
and Graber have pointed out so money is
life money is human life many of us in
anthropology of money write about money
as a great record of all of the
transactions that take place among
humans you don't need any material token
to symbolize that all you need is some
system of record-keeping and also at the
origin of the systems of record-keeping
that we see give rise to the thing that
then recognizably becomes money to those
of us in the capitalist West at that
origin point there are living things
like these grains of barley here on the
left
the earliest transactional records on
cuneiform tablets essentially were
marking relations of credit and debt
among people both over barley and
denominated in terms of barley in the
ancient Near East at the mundane level
those sort of early receipts were about
this stuff of subsistence at the
prestige level among those who were
keeping track of those records holding
them in great storehouses and temples
prestige items circulated across the
ancient world that often again index the
materiality of life behind if you will
money so we have objects like this thing
in the middle from Anatolia somewhere
between a thousand and 2,000 BC that's a
oxen cart a prestige item would have
circulated among people of a certain
social status and then on the far right
is a big silver crater a wine vessel it
would have held wine circulating in the
region
that the Phoenicians colonize out to the
west of Europe again the wine a living
thing the kind of coming of the money
that were more familiar with it took
this form comes when the kings and
tyrants as they were called broke up
those ancient hoards of records in
temples and storehouses liberated if you
want to use a contemporary discourse to
think about it liberated silver that had
been accumulating there in the form of
tribute items and started imprinting
with it their own sign stamping with it
the sign of the sovereign you can see
King Darius here on this coin which used
to be in my possession but was stolen
from me in Argentina it's a long story
anyhow but what I find so delightful
about these objects is even though there
was an effort to kind of seal off
clothes off those human social
relationships by cementing it in a coin
and stamping it with the mark of the
sovereign people didn't quite get what
this thing was for and so what did they
do well they adopted the same in in
script oriole culture that they had
before when they were writing out things
on papyrus or clay tablets and marked
these coins with their own mark and you
can see these little punch marks on the
front and on the back but that someone
basically people were endorsing these
things over to one another because they
didn't get that this thing could serve
as a token of value in itself if you're
coming from a world where money is life
this dead object doesn't make any sense
unless you give it new life by endorsing
it over to the next person into whose
possession it it comes now in this
deadening world of this kind of coinage
despite the inscriptions on them hello
there
we have commentators philosophers
Aristotle worrying about this kind of
coming of a new new culture of the coin
and Aristotle seeing this new world many
of you are familiar with the way in
which he decried it and said that this
is in fact
natural thing coin as money seems to
continually reproduce itself in
inanimate nonliving saying making more
of itself and so Aristotle famously
argued against the the making of money
with money as a way to justify the civic
virtues of landed estates and famously
declared money to be unnatural and
against that that order of landed
estates not to say that landed estates
are great by the way right this is
there's no there's no good or bad in the
story it's just what is the Aristotelian
position on money got Christianized and
in the Middle Ages were familiar with
the the Christian discourse that
basically took the Aristotle's language
of money being unnatural and translated
the unnatural into the satanic and so
this is just a close-up of the triptych
you just saw you can see can you see it
you can see the little demons here in
hell and see the but right there there's
a little but pooping pooping money out
and you can see that little coins yeah
so money Satan [ __ ] excretion
money gets deadened in this period and
linked to the earthly but not in the
sense that we were just discussing there
is a counter movement to this of course
and and my tale today is very much of a
dialectic between two different visions
of the life of money to this earthy in
the bad sense money the emerging
mercantilist discourse drew very much on
another metaphor of life the metaphor of
circulation of the blood popularized in
william harvey 1628 book on circulation
which cath Weston has shown feeds right
into political economy of the day
justifying mercantilism and flows of
money as life again not as not as [ __ ]
or as deaf to this circulatory metaphor
though
again in a kind of counter movement the
the physiocrats like Francois kezzeme
here linked money back to the soil back
to the soil against the self-expansion
airy character and qualities of the
emerging capitalism that Harvey
circulatory metaphor animated so I just
want want you to have in your mind these
kind of different notions of the life of
money the life of money as the human
social relationships that then can get
sealed up in a deadened object which
then can get linked to the excretion of
life which can then be revalued again by
the physiocrats as the soil of life the
soil of value with this vision playing
off against that circulatory vision
money as a circulation or money as
finance let's fast forward to Earthrise
and think about the physiocrats
today some of the stuff that Claire was
just talking about in her work finds
expression in some pretty important
foundational essays late in the last
century that were postulating the planet
as the natural limit to growth to
economic growth and you see playing out
now is similar dialectic between finance
and physiocratic motions of money in
ideas of natural capital and of trying
to value so-called ecosystem services
the things that the value that is
generated by the living activity of the
planet so that it can enter into
economic relationships devalued the
accounted for
Robert Costanza in 1997 wrote a germinal
paper on ecosystem services which might
be on the next slide but maybe isn't
well this is from it that postulates
this sort of series of systems and makes
a point that the natural capital of
so-called ecosystem services really
envelops all of the social built in
human capital in in our economy
Costanza and others working in this
trajectory even postulated and this was
for Claire specifically soil capital and
soil money to really think about the
soil functions that then feed into the
generation of added value for human
populations there are a number of ways
in this in which this idea has been
literalized
in proposals for physical currency
objects that derive from the natural
world the Eco was one such proposal by
the next Nature Network and
interestingly then a contemporary
cryptocurrency ties itself to the value
of carbon again think carbon in the
petrochemical petrol industrial complex
world as a kind of death but also
remember that it is the foundation of
life then here in an interesting way
harking back to those ancient coins with
its iconography but taking us into the
carbon cycle as a new means of value now
i it would be wrong to just kind of
leave it at that and not point out that
there are the folks out there who see
any speculation on such alternative
monetary forms as one step closer to
one-world government right so I have a
slide here from technocracy watch which
is what it sounds like they're kind of
worried about you know the the technique
of North America issuing universal
identity cards with chips on them that
are keeping track of your carbon output
and giving you carbon credits and see
carbon currency is the Vanguard for one
world government be that as it may I
actually find some comfort and solace in
our own us banknotes which remained
which are becoming more and more unique
in the world as physical objects because
as they are still made out of the cotton
rag linen fiber blend that we've been
using for around a hundred years they're
interesting reasons why they're unlikely
to be replaced by polymer like you see
in other countries one of the reasons is
that the people who make the money know
that our banknotes American banknotes
serve as a store of value for people all
over the world for a villager in India
who is saving money they're likely to
save us banknotes in a jar in a clay
vessel buried in the backyard
these things need to last linen is
remarkably durable this our our stuff
here has a shelf life undisturbed of
around 30 40 even 50 years because of
its natural composition and there's
another thing I'd just like to point out
before I close that I find delightful
about the new u.s. hundred dollar bill
in designing the security features for
it that that one one of which is that
blue reflective strip the folks at the
Bureau of Engraving and printing
realized that they had at their disposal
a terrific way to make every single one
of these objects unique and the way to
do it was to rely on the qualities of
the natural fibers making up the bill
itself if you if you if you have a
hundred I do not you know that there's
this little strip and there are these
paper bridges that seem to hold the
strip in place the edges of those
bridges are defined by individual flax
fibers in the slurry that makes up the
paper so instead of sort of putting it
through some kind of mechanical process
that then cuts those edges to make them
nice and clean the slurry is allowed to
do however it works someone must be a
paper maker here it does what it does
and route and you get that you get that
that nice wavy thing that nice wavy line
every one of which is different so if
you have a hundred you should look at it
if it's a straight edge it's a fake and
you should call the police okay this is
a way in which
the circulatory notion of money and the
the physiocratic notion of money remains
bonded in the very stuff of American
currency I think there's a lesson in
this banknote for us today and I'll
leave it at that so we have time for
discussion
[Applause]